and there's this quote from one of my
friends Alex homozy that says you don't
become Confident by shouting
affirmations in the mirror but by having
a stack of undeniable proof that you are
who you say you are outwork yourself
doubt a lot of people are like no but
what if you don't have any successes
like how do you get started they don't
realize the validity of the smaller
things that they have done up to that
point did you get dressed this morning
did you get in front of the computer
it's smaller evidence but you have
enough evidence to make the claim that
you can do this you do that enough times
that you have enough evidence to make a
claim that you can do this and support
it but that's the idea is just stacking
as many of those pieces of evidence that
give you proof that you are who you say
you are